the rabbi got so pissed that I spoke
Swahili from the vemma he refused to do
my wedding
our bar mitzvah is basically like a
wedding exactly not right a passage she
to Jewish adulthood and by Jewish
adulthood I mean absorbing as much
humiliation as you can possibly absorb
in like a three to four hour period Bar
Mitzvah is like the best party ever just
wasted on 13 year olds you know being
from the Torah you give a speech then
there's a big party so that's me stop
that's my sister and that tall man did I
buy gold that's a party
holy everything's everything's gold be
like you're still smiling through the
pain so here's me on the chair see I
never got lifted on the chair they even
bother they lifted my parents on the
chair there's my two younger brothers on
wait at your bar mitzva my bar mitzvah
but they did not raise me you just look
like a classic Jewish kid except two
feet smaller and very confused my
grandma had passed away like a few
months before my Bat Mitzvah and my best
friend's grandmother who I drove my
whole life
she was there and she was like I'm you
know here in her honor I'm your
surrogate Bubbe she was 75 at the time
she made out with my DJ on the dance
floor
hahahaha you look like Ron Weasley so
here's me in this chicken hat that I
wore like all night and my dad like kept
begging me to take it off but it's in
like all the pictures though here is me
and my dad and my mom my two brothers
hmm you are looking super 13 right there
ah this isn't here oh my god there's
just no way to take an awkward photo at
a bar mitzvah I want you to be my son
this is like a pre exposed titty shut up
on that chairman Jim Jackson has nothing
on my mom both both ladies okay every
boy in my seventh grade class sorry mom
you have a nice rack it's fine
and afterwards I asked my mom if I could
just take my best friend on a cruise and
so we went on a cruise with my best
friend
yeah honeymoon instead of America I just
want to point out that we are exact
opposite Bar Mitzvah kids I only had a
bar mitzvah so I could have a party I
didn't even really believe in Judaism
they didn't even have Pinterest back
then oh so how are you supposed to plan
a freaking party yeah it's terrifying to
me is that I have a six year old
daughter which means that I will have
some years to save footage they're
expensive overall I feel like barn bat
mitzvahs are I mean they're a rite of
passage but I feel like at the time you
don't realize that yeah I don't know I
did it for the party and it was a great
party and I'd do it again for the party
Smith who the takasho Marissa Marissa
Marissa McClure help